how much is thirteen billion dollars
worth it's enough to put you in the top
100 richest people in the world or
outrank 70 countries GDPs it's also the
annual revenue pharmaceutical companies
generate on ADHD medication in the
United States ADHD diagnosis have been
on the rise in the last decade putting
it second only to asthma as the most
common childhood diagnosis for many of
the eleven percent of the kids in
America with an ADHD diagnosis the
answer has been to throw pills at the
problem but is it effective one study
that followed students for more than
three years didn't find any increase in
performance or improved grades the in
fetta mean adderall is chemically
similar to methamphetamine and causes a
similar reaction in the brain both
increased synaptic levels of dopamine
norepinephrine and serotonin the
long-term effects of amphetamine abuse
on the brain are not totally known and
some researchers believe long-term usage
could lead to permanent damage many of
the trials of amphetamines that
established it as safe were tested on
rodents in short high doses which is
very different than incremental
long-term usage in humans but what about
the organizations that protect
jack-and-jill hyperactive over time the
American Psychiatric Association has
expanded the symptoms for diagnosis
causing some to think finances is a
motivating factor the APA receives
between 20 and 30% of their yearly
funding from drug companies one of the
leading ADHD advocacy groups Chad
receives around 1 million a year from
pharmaceutical institutions and the FDA
well half a billion dollars a year of
its budget comes from the fees that drug
companies give it to look at their new
drugs one group that profits from more
diagnosis and more prescriptions are
those who take the amphetamine
medication recreationally
between 2006 and 2011 the number of
people abusing ADHD medication
skyrocketed from 4.7 million to 8.2
million adderall is the second most
takin drug among high school seniors and
one poll found that between 16 to 29
percent of students with prescriptions
have been asked to give sell or trade
their medication from Big Pharma to the
black market ADHD is a profitable
diagnosis